[تصفيق]
ولاول مره عنيت يعلنوا عن اول تحرك عسكري
ضد روسيا في العالم
تضع شرطا واحدا
للسلاميسكي يشكك في حلفائه الغربيين
ويتهمهم بالخيانه وباريس تعلنها صراحه لقد
فشل الاوكرانيون في الحرب ونتائج انتخابات
مقاطعات اوكرانيا المنضمه الى روسيا تظهر
والكرملين ابرز الفائزين وبيلاروسيا اننا
نضبط انفسنا بصعوبه امام انتهاكاتكم وعداد
الضحايا في المغرب لا يتوقف والدول تهرع
للمساعده لتنتقل الكارثه الى ليبيا والاف
الضحايا يواجهون الفاجعه ومصر على موعد مع
المصيبه والسلطات تتاهب وللمره الاولى وفد
الاسرائيلي في السعوديه فهل تعلن ارض
الحرمين التطبيع وقطار يعود الى الواجهه
فالى اين الوجهه
واشنطن تضع شرطا واحدا الحرب مستمره
وخسائر الغرب والاوكران في ازدياد ولكن
امريكا لا زالت تكابر وتصر على شروطها وهو
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان الشرط
العادل للشروع في مفاوضات سلام بين موسكو
يجب ان يكون قائما على الاعتراف بما قال
عنها وحده اراضي اوكرانيا وزعم بلينكن في
مقابله مع قناه اي بي سي نيوز الامريكيه
انه في الوقت الحالي لا وجود لاي مؤشرات
تدل على ان لدى الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اهتماما باي دبلوماسيه هادفه لياتي
الدور على اكبر منافسي امريكا نعم انه
التنين الصيني حيث قال ماونينجا المتحدث
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان مفتاح حل
الازمه الاوكرانيه يكمن في التخلي عن
عقليه الحرب البارده واكد ان الصين ستظل
ملتزمه بالسلام والمفاوضات وستعمل مع
المجتمع الدولي عزيزي تسويه سياسيه للازمه
الاوكرانيه برايكم ايهما اقرب لحل الازمه
الراي الامريكي ام الراي الصيني من جانبه
حلف النيتو يتجاهل كل تلك التوترات لتكشف
صحيفه
2024 اكبر تحرك عسكري باجراء اضخم مناورات
له منذ ايام الحرب البارده وذلك تحت اسم
المدافع الصلب وقالت الصحيفه من المتوقع
ان يشارك ما لا يقل عن 41 الف جندي واكثر
من 50 سفينه في مناورات المدافع الصلب
وسيتم تنفيذ ما بين 500 الى 700 طلعه جويه
خلالها وذلك بالقرب من الحدود الروسيه
وبالتحديد في المانيا وبولندا والدول
البلطيق فهل تكون هذه التحركات سببا في
اندلاع حرب عالميه والى الحرب الاوكرانيه
على الارض حيث اك الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ان الهجوم المضاده الذي شنته اوكرانيا
يبقى اكثر صعوبه مما توقعته لاسباب منها
ان روسيا كانت مستعده له بشكل جيد ليرد
الرئيس الاوكراني
انه بدا يشك في صدق بعض حلفائك الذين
زعموا انهم سيدعمون دائما القوات
الاوكرانيه وذلك وفق مجله
البريطانيه الرد على
المانيا حيث اعلن المكتب الصحفي لشركه
الدفاعيه الالمانيه ان الشركه ستقوم بامر
من الحكومه الالمانيه بتزويد اوكرانيا
باربعين مركبه مشاه قتاليه اخرى من طراز
ماردر لتشتعل التوترات اكثر وهنا تعلن
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في تقريرها اليومي
بان خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه بلغت نحو 675
عسكريا خلال يوم على مختلف المحاور
المصدر كما نتصفحه في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه المانيا لم تكتفي بذلك
وارسلت وزيره خارجيه انا زياره غير معلنه
الى بحسب وكاله فما الذي يجري من تحت
الطاوله هذه المره وفي اوكرانيا ايضا ولكن
في المقاطعات التي انضمت الى روسيا حيث
قالت مفوضيه الانتخابات المحليه الروسيه
ان حزب روسيا الموحده
باكثر من 70% من الاصوات في اربعه مناطق
[موسيقى]
وهنا ننتقل الى الجاره الى روسيا حيث اعلن
مساعد وزير الدفاع البيلاروسيا
تحاول التصرف بضبط نفسه عندما تنتهك
طائرات بدون طيار تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
حدودها مضيفا نحن نفهم الاستراتيجيه نحن
بحاجه الى تفاهم متبادل طبيعي وعلاقات و
مع اوكرانيا غضب الطبيعه الافريقيه حاله
كارثيه غير مسبوقات تعيشها الدول العربيه
في افريقيا والناس لا حول لهم ولا قوه
امام غضب الطبيعه باراده الخالق وبعد
الزلزال المروع في المغرب اعلنت السلطات
ان الترددات الاهتزازيه قد تعود مره اخرى
دعايه للمواطنين الى توخي الحذر وبشده مما
كانت وزاره الداخليه المغربيه قد قالت ان
السلطات استجابت لعروض دعم قدمتها اسبانيا
وقطر والمملكه المتحده والامارات التي
اقترحت تعبئه مجموعه من فرق البحث
والانقاذ مضيفه ان عداد الضحايا وصلحت
صناعه هذا الفيديو الى
2681 قتيلا وتمكنت السلطات من دفن
2530 شخصا منهم مما بلغ عدد الجرحى
2501 وهي حصيله غير نهائيه فما زال تحت
الانقاض ولا احد يعلم نهايتهم من المغرب
الى الجاره ليبيا الفاجعه واحده ولكن ليس
بالزلزال هذه المره وانما بقوه الاعصاب
حيث قال رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان اسامه حماد عدد ضحايا العاصفه
دانيال في درنه يتخطى ال 2000 مشيرا الى
ان المفقودين بالالاف لتضعنا هذه العاصفه
في مصر حيث اطلقت السلطات المصريه تحذيرا
من تاثر البلاد بالعاصفه دانيال التي ضربت
اليونان مؤخرا اتجهت نحو سواحل ليبيا
والتي تقترب من الحدود الغربيه لمصر ليعلن
المصريون حاله التاهب القصوى فعن اي فاجعه
نتحدث
الاحداث والتطورات نقلت وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه عن مسؤول اسرائيلي قوله ان وفدا
اسرائيليا يشارك في اجتماع لمنظمه الامم
للتربيه والعلم والثقافه اليونسكو يعقد في
الرياض وذلك في اول زياره معلنه لوفد
اسرائيلي الى المملكه التي لا تربطها
علاقات مع تل ابيب هل حان وقت التطبيع مع
الكيان ابناء المملكه وماذا عن
الفلسطينيين بعد ان خرجت التقارير بقرب
اجتماع زعيم كوريا الشماليه
غادر قطار كوري شمالي يعتقد انه يقل
الزعيم في طريقه الى روسيا لعقد اجتماع
محتمل بين الرئيسين حسبما ذكرت وسائل
اعلام كوريه الجنوبيه هل سيعلن الزعيمان
عن التحالف رسميا ضد الغرب ام انهما
سيحضران لخططهما ولكن بسريه تامه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان انه ناقش مع
الوكيل العالم للشؤون الانسانيه الوضع
بالبلد والاستعداد لتقديم كافه التسهيلات
للوصول المساعدات الى مس تحقيها من جهه
ثانيه ادت مواجهه طرفي الصراع الى سقوط
اكثر من اربعين قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى بعد
قصف من الجيش على معاقل الدعم السريع بسوق
شعبي جنوب السودان